okay hello everyone I am back on Jess
comm for what's supposed to be the arena
kings except I don't know if it's
happening let me open the chat chat or
are you hello Jennifer - and hello the
Gaga genka in Belgium novice well this
is slightly concerning I just see that
chess comm is doing this mvl comodo
match which is exciting but does that
mean arena kings is not happening if
anyone knows if arena Kings is happening
I don't see the tournament in the in the
listings here people see this yeah
people can see that so usually a pops up
like before the tournament starts let me
go and check I swear I saw this
scheduled on the site's arena Kings
chess calm yeah and then maybe this one
No the event is canceled that's so sad I
wish there was more notice because I
went to this page yesterday and like
they didn't have this message that's
really sad
well I guess that means I will be
streaming something else because okay
there's already people watching I'm I
freed up this timeslot just to stream so
what to do let me uh let me rearrange
things here there we go this is gonna
just take a moment I have to move this
here and then move this over here
and then oh no I lost the checked wait
there we go okay
back to usual I will change the stream
title huh
let me let me make sure the board is
okay
yeah the board is framed nicely all over
my my event list has changed because I
was playing around with it I can make
that Center people are sending me
challenges already people know what's up
wait oh I want the chat here okay there
we go
is that better people can see and hear
me and let me know if there's any
improvements that can be made yeah I
think that was a pretty quick redesign
oh I have to change the title - I call
this what's today what is today today's
Wednesday
um want some clever name
today's a fifth of September
if anyone can think of a stream name for
me I will I'll be forever grateful
back to school back to school mm okay
I'm just gonna mention a chest oh I'm
just gonna make the stream title leech
acid org that will be simple enough and
then they should detect my stream at
some point so my next scheduled stream
of people can't see this but nice
scheduled stream is this a Lee chest
titled arena which is happening in a
couple days and then I guess arena Kings
will happen next week I have to check
their schedule again anyway uh let's do
something just related let's go and play
someone let's play mat shout out to mat
Wednesday war here
good luck mat oh let's play d4 I played
mat over the board not too long ago put
up a tough fight I'll play it London I'm
just closing all the apps on my phone so
it doesn't die so quickly okay c5 so I
actually have a story about this
position I'm gonna go ahead and play e4
I play the tournament over the weekend
and my opponent had played c5 like just
blitzed it out and I blitzed out III and
I was really disappointed myself for not
considering efore cuz it's actually a
really interesting line like a reverse
Alban counter gambit knight c6 so he
doesn't take either pawn seems
reasonable
now do I let's keep all the tension try
and just create a confusing position how
long is the stream going to be probably
an hour and a half that would be my best
guess I will probably upload this to
youtube in the future and then people in
the youtube comments can say how wrong I
am
I like my position I'm developed for the
most parts let's continue developing all
my minor pieces this is like one of
these French variations but maybe my
bishop is misplaced enough for I don't
know we need to check as a move we'll
start with we need to check to the king
Bishop e6 could happen yeah I have to do
something about this bishop I could take
and then take not sure if that helps
could play 95 I'm not sure if that helps
even 95 we trade let's play 95 looks
interesting I'm pressuring c6 but my
knight is kind of pinned so I'm not
entirely sure what's going on I can take
with the bishop if I take take take
Queen c7 I take on d6 takes back I move
my knight humans d4 gets a bit messy I
could take on c5 first that might just
went up on unless it doesn't win a pawn
this is such a confusing position just
have to rely on intuition hello to Paige
out Oh a knight 84 I did not see
oh wait nothing was on d4 so it's just
like 2d for my pawn used to be on d4
that's a good move let's play Queen d3
so I'm not waiting upon okay let's just
Castle and get some hopefully playable
position you should have five so much
initiative my queen doesn't have too
many options let's play Queen d2 now I
might be losing a pawn c2 is falling
this is slightly uncomfortable Kluth is
back hello clooth Matos yeah i'm
streaming at a new time I meant if you
just joined I started the stream on
Jeff's calm because I thought the arena
Kings was happening but unfortunate it's
not I guess I I didn't check the
schedule soon enough but I will play the
leech s titled arena in a couple days
that's a plan at least so now he's
debating if he wants to take the pawn
because when he takes a pawn he opens my
C file like Knight takes you to okay I'm
happy with this so now I saved the pawn
feel like a knight take c2 is the best
move what is going on here so much
confusion Queen d1 I'm okay with the
double pawns f6 I really want to take
here and then there would be four nights
in the center but then he wins my knight
on e5 wait till I have that no I didn't
have that as an option let's just go
back he's playing well to keep some
initiative but at least I'm solid now
things are under control
we'll probably trade a few pieces and I
just want some positional game like
something I can start grinding in terms
of positional chess
if he who if he takes on d3 I think I
can take Wayne oh then he takes the rook
life is complicated you want me to play
a Carroll Khan I could try and play a
Carol Khan Amin Zamani I completely
forgot to respond to your message
because I've been bogged down like the
amount of messages I've been getting on
a daily basis especially through we
chess it's been a lot let me see if I
can respond if I don't respond within an
hour after his stream ends remind me
that'll be the most convenient approach
d4 g4
yeah now we just have some kind of
equalist position objectively that might
be slightly better but in blitz
objective evaluation is to always mean
that much I could take the night here
seems appealing yeah let's take the
night because now I'm creating some
imbalance or I'll have a night versus a
bishop and my queen is strong a for
trying to restrict b5 and I want to play
like rook b1 at some points between d3
rook e1 immediately let's play rook e1
immediately
be six what to do maybe rook fc-1 queen
d3 defending and attacking rook c4 is a
good move
matt is playing well matt has improved
like over the last recent times 92 i'm
gonna tempt him to take the pawn and
then i'll proceed to try and trap his
rook but maybe I'll just win back the
pawn this one back upon his rook is
undefended so his bishop is pinned
please turn volume up okay sound levels
I'm I'm showing proof here that I'm
turning my volume up let me know if
that's better or worse hopefully it's
better I'm using my mic it's at minus 10
DB to like reduce background noise
because my computer foo free rook my
computer my computer fan is a bit crazy
when I stream so hopefully it's okay I
know sometimes it varies if you're using
headphones or you're listening through
speakers or if you have hearing problems
yeah good game Matt Matt play the great
game until he punch her
rook by this position it's tricky maybe
he should I don't know defend the rook
here like Queen d7 hey it's a sub Johnny
pedants
thanks Johnny although John's in the
chat John John 1 3 4 maybe just two
John's so far hello to everyone that I
didn't say hello to can you move the
board a bit to left yes ooh yeah what is
this this is a byproduct of switching
over websites too quickly hopefully
that's better thanks guys for helping me
improve the the quality let me know if
there's anything else I can do
oh this - oh wait where does this go
yeah there we go just put that right
there
cool Paul cacao ski thanks for the
follow
I usually don't give a follow shoutouts
anymore but that was good timing do I
give take-backs for obvious blunders it
depends if it's bullet then no usually
only for obvious mouse slips but it
really depends how I feel
rookie - I mean it was clearly not a
mouse slip I am not married fortunately
or unfortunately I don't know yet to
find out yeah if the volume was too loud
just turn down your volume now so what
do I want to do could play someone else
yeah let's play someone else give me a
random number between 1 and 6
um oz I was
biggis okay good luck house biggest
rated 1570 I've never played him before
what's he's from Lafayette I was in LA
via what was I in Lafayette a couple
summers ago
no last summer like a year and three
months ago but he's not moving
he said hello and good luck in the chat
but I know what's going on here I was in
Lafayette for two weeks I played some
small like rapid event and I played a
shear of and sveshnikov in the same
event and I got crushed by both of them
and both games are on YouTube someone
was filming them so now we have a London
this is exciting
90 c6 Bishop b5 okay this is new
actually Bishop e5 is an interesting
move but I don't know how great it is in
this position because Queen b6 happens
and this is should be problematic for
him
because now I'm attacking the b-pawn I
also want to play Bishop a6 and just
control all the light squares thinking
Queen B for it but I'll take the pawn
another sub mellow dota thanks for the
sub okay so I think the plan in this
position is to I mean I want to get you
5 in so I'm thinking just 97 and he 5 is
really hard to stop what is with all
these subs thank you've lost ER 3 6 9
okay I'm gonna play e5 he's trying
really hard to Castle meanwhile I just
want to take over the center I'm gonna
play Age 5 threatening to drop the
bishop so H four okay
Queen B 5 doesn't make any sense cuz
Knight c3 happens so I don't think I can
prevent him from castling now unless I
can play this in this Jack she looks
very feasible because I want I want this
him to be tied down to this night on e -
oh he can play Knight c3 Knight BC 392
okay now I get my my wish and now both
his king and the Queen are tied down to
the Knights and f3 I wanted to take and
take here and that could actually win
upon if I win g4 in the end but I want
to keep Queens on the board I'm a jeast
oh yeah I've been missing you watching
my streams but good to see you back how
do I defend against a sub attack there's
no defense to the sub attack ok this is
winning a piece
yeah Queen g6 was was still preventing
him from castling from a tactical
standpoint now I would like to meet him
but that might be difficult unless this
Oh No okay everything is winning let's
play Bishop d6 I think I want to play e4
eventually provoke at four and then
bring my Knight to g4 you also just win
the h4 pawn let's take on each for free
material is always nice whoo check me
this nice - that was nice he was trying
to run away but yeah that that's in
quite work good game
what went wrong yeah I don't think there
should be five is a great move in that
position there are cases where there
should be five is playable for a future
reference the move to play in this
position is Knight bTW - because c3 runs
into Queen b6 but when you play Knight
bTW - Queen b6 can be met with do you
take c5 and these are some interesting
lines which I play myself is white I'm
Hillary my dude is asking about why
Bishop g3 is it's is good instead of
trading dark red bishops for example in
the London yes so there's a well-known
line in the London let's say okay let's
say Knight d2 e 695 let's say e6 c3
bishop why is it lagging so much
I mean disable stockfish I wasn't even
turned on so let's say it's a situation
like this and the bishops are seeing
each other and maybe you've seen my
lectures before where I say the
principal move here is to play Bishop g3
and leave the tension there's a few
reasons for this one reason is that
white is very happy if black takes
because an h-file opens and especially
if black castles this can lead to a
devastating attack I've actually I've
seen some games once or some games at
some points where after like Bishop d3
b6y to move and win like white is just
winning here there
there's actually just a forcing
combination so I'll actually let people
like try and guess in the chat wait to
move in this position find the strongest
move do not watch my stream and drive
that's dangerous you can listen to the
stream and drive put it on like audio
only mode but try not try to focus on
their road please one person saying
Knight g5 this runs into g6 or h6 my
chief I've is not the strongest move
Bishop take h7 night take age 7 what's
the follow-up h6 well a lot of people
saying Bishop take age 7 but what's the
follow-up after Knight take age 7 rook
take h7 and I take h7 very similar story
oh you want to take on h7 wait that
doesn't work at all cuz Queen take g5
you're trying a great gift but you're
just losing all your pieces so far I
only see one correct answer who is this
person
Kluth clothes got it 95
good job Kluth 95 is a strongest move
and it doesn't look that strong when you
first see it but there's two threats the
obvious threat is Knight takes c6 and
the second most obvious threat is Bishop
take h7 which black can't defend both
like if I take e5 pawn to g5 then age 7
is lost or the knight is lost
oh there's this move forgot about 94 but
this is still like overwhelmingly strong
just okay take on e4 and then you're
forking h7 in this white will be winning
like two pawns that's probably the best
line for black if black were to defend
the knight on c6 then Bishop take h7 and
if bishop or not can you take it if
Knight take h7 then there's queen h5 and
this is unstoppable mate I believe
like there's no road nowhere for the
King to run if rook you you take on f7
and Knight g6 meet what else can I show
Bishop take h7 I'll say King h8 this is
always a tricky situation there's
actually a really nice combination here
which okay I won't make people suffer
I'll just go ahead and show it uh I
believe Y can win the Queen by force and
this could be this could be an annoying
thing for for white to deal with because
there's so many different possibilities
of checking but there's I don't think
there's any force mates so I believe the
strongest continuation here is Bishop g6
King g8 and then Bishop take f7 with
idea after rook take f7 light wins the
Queen rook h8
good job John John King big H 8 and 9 f7
winning the Queen by force so this is a
cool line this was kind of a long
tangent to illustrate how white makes
use of the open H file but yeah I
normally White is happy with this trade
especially if black castles if black
doesn't Castle kingside
then the King either has to stay in the
centre or Castle queenside that's also
Pleasant for whites one more thing I'll
say if like that's the structure usually
it's a decent idea to like develop the
bishop and if necessary play King f1
later when you keep your rook on the
Open File and then maybe someday you'll
go for a for the other reason you don't
play I mean there's reasons to reject
other moves like you don't want to play
Bishop take g6 because that Jeff's just
helped Spock activate the Queen and
allows back to play e5 next move which
just completely equalizes maybe gives
back a better position
95 is another move but I forget what's
wrong with it maybe black can just take
with the bishop and then go after this
pawn like Knight f3 Queen c7 white might
be losing upon so yeah the rule is play
Bishop g3 hope that answered your
question
so your coach told you to play Bishop g3
okay that's okay that's good to see
oh I'll show one more secrets
this is secret preparation in the London
let's say e6 III Bishop d6 this just
demonstrates like one exception to the
rule let's flip the board let's say
we're playing white based on what we
just saw Bishop g3 is like the principle
move however in this position I think
the strongest move is actually to take
on g6 because White has a really nice
resource Queen to g4 creating a
situation where it's kind of annoying
for back to the Fen g7 Acura Black has
to either play g6 or Queen f8 or King f8
I've had games before where my opponents
play this and then trying win b2 and
then black is losing cuz rook b1 and
then white is winning the Jeep on in the
Queen next move okay so hopefully that's
just a quick quick lesson that people
can apply in their own games especially
for the London players out there let's
move on is Kluth challenging me
I wanted to play clooth because it was
the only person that suggested Knight e5
but clue if you still exists feel free
to send me a challenge and maybe I'll
accept
I'm waiting
otherwise I'll just do random numbers
okay random numbers it is give me a
random number between one and nine Oh
Cho hey this person is was this one the
new follower this is someone good luck
oh I'm white cypher first let's play e
for this game trying to fix this just a
little bit maybe I should I should get
rid of some of the things let me do this
okay
I'm fiddling around here also this could
be a strong player from Germany okay
this is five Oh blitz let's be careful
here there we go I think that's better
now I have slight slight perfectionism
disorder okay
let's play Bishop e5 play aggressive
this interesting line I used to play
this like as my main repertoire now I
just play it in blitz I try and speed
things up too
there is no increment ya a six is a good
move
I had this position against Eric Hanson
and then over the board tournament a few
weeks ago and it was also a 5-0
I managed like Fagin with one second
left
Bishop g6 what does this move maybe f4
f4 looks decent going for a five opinion
on the Leningrad Dutch I don't really
have any opinions on the Dutch it's an
opening it had it's it's trendiness at
the highest levels back when Fabiano and
carlson were playing it they played at
some point maybe they were playing
Stonewall Dutch but it's an opening I
don't think the computer fully
understands because it always gives
whites
I got Pleasant slight advantage but from
a practical standpoint it's very
playable you just have to be aware of
gambits when you play the Dutch is black
King h1 is typical Sicilian move
especially when f4 is played d5 does
that just lose a pond know that I can't
count okay I have to move back
maybe Bishop a - I don't know why I
couldn't count there I had three
defenders so I might go for a five yeah
II five I have a time advantage now the
knight has to retreat this is a very
good situation where the pawn restricts
and knights and I'm attacking his uh his
C pawn and he just gave me the e4 square
and he made my bishop happier he made
two pieces happier with one move that
was very nice of him but he does gain
some sight space and he opens up this
diagonal I really want to play f5 at
some points I'm gonna start with Queen
g3 I'm just going for some King side
attack are there any mods here
there should be some mods maybe there
aren't
I'm a mod I'm the ultimate mod Oh what
did I do
I want to play Knight f6 I also want to
play I don't know what tips like maybe
Knight g5 my g5 looks G since Omanis is
a mod sorry who can i mod that I know
come on Matt but I don't think Matt if
Matt are you still around I would trust
you as a mod let's play Queen h3 I have
a double threat threatening this and
this yes this might just wind up lot
actually it drops a rook that's nice
wait a minute my knight is pinned to my
queen I kind of forgot about that
there's so many pins my knight is pinned
because my pawn is pinned and now he's
attacking me
but I can move back because his H plot
as pins I've never seen so many pins
this is ridiculous
what does that move you just took a free
pawn well my knight is safe my C pawns
attacked I really want to like move my
bishop and just attack his Queen I think
I can get away with Bishop take f7 Queen
take a1 and Queen here cuz how is he
stopping mates let's do it
this is gonna be so beautiful if it
works if it doesn't work it's gonna be
so disappointing
cuz ice axe to the rook and now I'm
sacking the knight if he takes the
knight It's Made in one and meanwhile I
don't think you can defend queen h7 I
mean he has g6 but then just queen take
g6 this is so nice his queen is so out
of play uh yeah Bishop takes you to is
kind of expected it doesn't really help
them much okay yeah I'm gonna mud let's
mod some people mod what's his name
wait I have to still focus so now he's
sacking everything hoping to the fend g6
so he's just continually delaying mates
but now it's mate no matter what next
move right
no he resigns I wanted to pre move 1907
that was a really nice finish that was a
really weird situation too because there
were so many pins
like in his favor and in my favor yeah a
good game
Paul cacao ski in the chats ok matt is
how am i mod dead man DM so now we have
some more mods cool and we have a new
sub a toad in the wild jungle - I'm
surprised I was able to read that like
without stumbling
thanks for the sub why did you take the
rook instead of Knight g5 because of the
pins
he explained so we got ok we got to this
position where like he had a strong
Bishop I had some attack now I was I was
so excited with this move I kind of
forgot about the ramifications of after
h6 and I take you 6 the fact that my
pawn is not actually defending my Queen
because of this pin so my knight is
pinned to my queen but when he played
yeah when he played King H aids
thankfully ok if I take the rook which
someone was asking about he would take
my Queen and that would be really bad
but thankfully I was able to play Knight
g5 for a couple reasons first of all his
Queen was undefended and there is a pin
here and my knight defends the Queen
backwards some great geometry here and
then he took there and then I took there
and then h7 was an issue for him I was
kind of hoping for this this eventual
mates we're in the final position I
would be down a rook and a knight but ok
good game and also Palka Kowski thanks
for the the sub I appreciate that and
thanks for the good game
am I gonna play title arena this Friday
yes I have in my calendar oh I forgot to
put in my my stream schedule calendar I
meant to do that
but yes I'm planning on playing
hopefully Carlson will play I don't know
if that's been confirmed yet or not show
some ideas about Kings Indian well let's
play a new player and I'll play Kings
Indian if I can give me a random number
between one and thirteen okay so 13 12
11 10 toab first so if he plays d4 I'm
playing the kid okay we're playing the
kid there is some funny posts like all
over social media about like husband and
wife the wife's at found like some some
notes from the husband and the note said
kill the kid and then she was so like
worried about like some some plots of
terribleness but then it was just like
chest notes like opening preparation
let's play this
I don't usually play the Kings Indian
defense but it's an opening I sometimes
teach to two students because it's a
very easy position to play for luck at
least early on like you almost always do
this the first first four moves and then
you play d6
or usually d6 will come after white
plays efore so we have a main line and
this is probably the most common
position that you'll get if you're a
Kings Indian player v5 is not supposed
to be a good move because it's
overextending it's also opening the
position when blacks king is already
castled
oh let's do this and I'm happy to trade
Queens because okay when he takes if he
takes back with pawn I'll trade Queens
and play Knight g4 if he takes back with
diets I'll probably end up thinking and
figure out something to do maybe 97 was
some eventually five break was now the
problem for him is that this Knight has
already moved twice and now I'm
attacking it so it's he's probably gonna
have to do something about it and that's
just slowing down his development I'm
trying to accelerate my development
Bishop g5 okay so he's developing so if
I take he takes play this his pawn is
weak he could take on d8 I take back and
then he takes on e7 but then I have
Ricky eight and I'll I'm guaranteed to
win the e pawn and then start attacking
this King even without Queens on the
board let's do that I guess he has f4
after a knight g4 but then I have 93
that should also be nice how do I like
the Alekhine's defense Alekhine's
defense is kind of a forgotten opening
at least for me I haven't seen it in
ages I wouldn't mind playing it from
time to time
Bishop take f6 well now this should just
easily allow me to win a pawn because I
can take and then just win this and I'll
have the bishop here too
[Music]
yeah when it comes to time controls it
doesn't really matter I just don't
accept correspondence I will accept yeah
anything reasonable wow so he's not
taking my night so now I'm just other
piece what I really want to do I'm gonna
do it this is such a hope chest move oh
shoot I lost uh
I forgot about this Fork he can fork me
on c7 that's not good well now it's
gonna be interesting
I'm very curious if he's if he was
watching the stream and and heard heard
me react this is the whole point that
yeah this is such a nice double check
means it doesn't happen too often
yeah Queen he ate of course like he
should take the Knights and then I would
take back it would still be a decent
position for black but that was a great
finish also he said something in the
chat yikes
oh good job on my videos well thank you
okay that was fun when are you going to
share your Buddha secrets I've already
shared them in a st. Louis chess club
lecture I showed some some games with
some classic ideas I know what their
secrets but it's a lecture called
Rosen's awesome miniatures and it should
be very findable on YouTube okay new
opponent okay I'm gonna play Kluth
because he found the right move earlier
and I tried playing him but there is no
challenge so now there's a challenge if
efore is played I've kind of want to
play in Alekhine's defense d4
I'll play another Kings Indian whoever
asked about the Kings Indian this is
your lucky day so Matt found the video
so this is a position where there's
actually two moves I'm in the castle
because e5 is not something black is
supposed to be scared of it does lead to
some interesting lines so okay we're
gonna have actually a very similar type
of position now this is playable for
white but it's actually I think this is
an easier position to play for black
even though it looks really ugly like
with all the pieces just looking so
passive kind of looks like Fischer
random chess but the whole idea is to
play d6 and c5 and just tear down the
pawns and apply pressure with the minor
pieces I forgot he's a decent player so
maybe I have to take this seriously not
underestimate him I'm actually not sure
what to take back with cuz like you take
with the C pawn and then redevelop my
Knights and develop this knight or I
take with a pawn and again redevelop my
Knights a little bit indecisive
now let me take kind of towards the
center this way maybe in the future I'll
have some ePHI break and I have very few
weaknesses here so that at least makes
me comfortable
pretty sure my knight wants to come back
I want to like do this in this but then
d5 happens maybe it's a trade-off
I'm thinking that it actually makes
sense just to trade off this Bishop like
whenever he plays h3 I'll just take on
that three and then develop the knight
to c6 because I do have slightly less
space with White's pawns and if you were
to play h3 before I could play Bishop g4
then I wouldn't be able to find a great
square for my bishop you never played
mainline yeah we kind of deviated from a
in line I guess I could have played d6
to try and get more of a mainline but he
could have played Knight f3 also
together main line
just remembered we never had a price
sack what's the price sack just giving
away money let's take and do this if he
plays g5 then my bishop becomes happier
everything becomes happier and meanwhile
I'm attacking d4 expecting something
like this now it does have a couple
advantages here a more space into
Bishops so I'm not sure what my argument
is for playing for some advantage maybe
the fact I have more Center pawns and I
will someday play e5 but do I player
right now I could also play f5 f5 is
really interesting threatening f4 it
weakens East six but that's not a
problem let's play f5 I'm just curious
what he's going to do
because he's not castled I'm making a
threat and it's not the easiest thing to
stop and d4 is the targets so King h8
now is Bishop as a target my knight can
come somewhere and target the bishop I'm
still threatening f4 and usually f5 will
combine at some point with e5 usually v
is played before f5 but no this seems
logical I don't think he wants to play
g3 whoa I didn't see that coming so okay
he gives back the the bishop here and
now the position has transformed f4 now
loses a pawn he five is a move rook b8
could be interesting
Queen a5 there's a lot of choices here I
want to keep the initiative somehow also
there's a move d5 which feels wrong but
it does fix his pawn and allows my
knight to come to a nice square on d6 it
just feels off I'm just gonna play rough
eh just flexible see what he's up to
make the Queen tied down to the b-pawn
and maybe it's just a matter of
improving the pieces and the position it
was imagining nice u7e six and then to
prepare a four but he would have g5 so
what to do maybe just Knight f6 that's
gonna be a longer fights ax villager a
long time no see it's been a really long
time good to see you back you have
another mod in the chat this used to be
a draw stream yeah so I was actually
planning a match a drops match against
another very well known streamer but
then the site was having some technical
issues so the match got cancelled but
there will probably be one later this
month so be prepared to see more drops
but anyway um I have to figure out the
plan like this is just kind of a slower
middlegame type of position Knight h5
could be really interesting I mean I
make my intentions very clear but I'd be
curious to see how he stops that for
overload
I could make jeremy ahmad then there
would be even more overload yes
penguin who I think he's a top ultra
bullet player on on the sites I was
looking at some of those games and it's
just it's ridiculous
he's so fast
axé villager don't apologize I'm in the
same boat time is time is so valuable
okay so now his bishop is a little bit
weird I'll play rook f7 I won't look
like Queen that fades and h6 and then
continually kick the bishop and some day
just keep expanding on the Kings side
I guess he's maybe targeting the e7 pawn
but Queen III could run into f4 and the
Queen is also tied down to the D pawn
rookie six unexpected well does this
move I forgot the square is not in my
control so can I get away with h6 I
think I can
h6 he takes I take he takes I play this
down a piece he would be down a piece he
would be winning some pawns
let's do it I'm not getting mated if you
sex now if you retreat some I'm also
happy those F work better before h6 yeah
maybe I just didn't want to commit to
overextending maybe he would have like
92 I don't know
or even f3 and then lock the bishop back
ok so now he's thinking to take on g6 or
not to take it's always nice when you
can just create a situation where the
opponent has to think and then well I
can just react to whatever he does
I guess he has like four or maybe only
three feasible options because Bishop
III runs into asked for
so there is two second increments
meaning there probably won't be any
dirty flags
maybe maybe f4 was still better but he
can't retreat to e3 that four is always
looming
and my phone is just like littered with
YouTube notifications
I really have to turn off notifications
for like for comments it just fills up
it's so distracting but good to see the
love on YouTube but now is it's time for
the twitch chats
who else is here so f/4 was way better
with a threat on the rope Queen can't
take I could go back after the game okay
Bishop h4 you know is he planning to
sack on g5 so we'll find out there's no
okay if Bishop g3 a for fishing h2 it's
kind of a sad Bishop and that my bishop
is happy if he takes takes takes my
knight has to go back and you does win
three pawns for the piece but usually
pieces are more valuable what to do a4
yeah let's play out four and then I
think the plan is to play Bishop at six
and Knight g7 and start improving at
least some minor pieces and just defend
everything - and kick the rook away it's
a nice maneuver and the problem for him
if he wants to have her free this Bishop
he has to weaken the Kings side so
that's problematic and I feel like I'm
just up a piece here how do you learn
opening theories etc or no Eric I
thought that said it's not her I mean
books are a good resource I used to
learn openings like primarily through
books also through my coach we just give
me recommendations nowadays I'm usually
using me chess opening explorer or chess
base a chess base like mega data based
so like kind of sort through a
collection of millions of games and see
what's being played more frequently at
the top levels let's play c5 it's weird
like all my pawns literally all my pawns
are in dark squares but this is a good
Bishop and it's a good Bishop because it
actually like the pawns compliment the
bishop where they help control some key
squares together usually the rule is
when you have a pawn chain you want the
bishop outside of the pawn chain in this
case the bishop is outside one pawn
chain and inside the other pawn chain so
it creates a sandwich like sandwiches
okay be 390 for this nice nice outpost
let's just keep improving gonna go for
this this is very positional and yeah
yeah my bishop is doing nothing except
my bishop is is holding a seven which is
useful in some cases I don't really want
to trade nights let's move back
maybe my bishop will come to d4 or maybe
I'll play Bishop e5 and just slowly
squeeze or comes to F faith and then
maybe someday I push I like positions
like this where there's very little risk
can just try a few different ideas see
what works it's hard for a white to find
any sort of active play looking for a
move here for a white the knight is
stuck my Knights tied down to the
fending c3 meaning this rook is kind of
stuck let's play we've got fates maybe I
allow him this move but that's okay
very soon I want to play f3 maybe I
could go play that three right away
it does open his bishop that I want
night each for
okay we'll see what happens so he plays
before now maybe it's a good time to
take his queen will come out of the play
then I'll start attacking f3 9h for this
night is still stuck because Bishop c3
is always looming so I think he has to
take and then I'll just put the knight
on h4 oh I forgot about that move but I
think it's blundering Bishop c3 because
I can take bishop c3 mm anything better
Bishop c3 right away also possible let's
take first
now as bishop is slightly more alive but
still restricted no I should be winning
material and Amun Samadhi is not driving
anymore that's good good job for
surviving dead man diem has to do some
actual work okay see you in the future
and yeah just disclaimer for everyone
who sent me messages after this stream I
will what does this move after the
stream I will be sorting through my
boatload of messages and responding to
people so just a heads up I can play
this and then all his pieces all his
major pieces would be hanging that's
okay
[Music]
now I can take the rook and now I'll
just be up a rook for free oh I forgot
about that move how do I forget about
that move Wow rook g6 that's not good
I'll still have two rooks for the Queen
but this is not what I wanted that's not
what I wanted at all okay
move back take on g7 with the king
objectively black should still be better
but it's gonna be tricky because he has
I'm so bad at counting he has a couple
pawns for the couple pawns in addition
to the Queen for the two rooks what to
do
my Bishop on c5 I want my bishop to
stand this diagonal
okay let's play Bishop pure and then
Bishop c5 he's gonna play Queen ooh look
fact in queen d3 when a forest seemed
this pointless so I can take now f2 is
pinned and attacked three times and he
has no calorie play and where's my mates
this is really interesting this game
transformed a lot looking for meat here
you see some idea let's test him
yeah so I was hoping for King g4 cuz I
don't think he has any defense to rook 8
f4 and now it should just be winning if
he played King g2 it would have been a
much harder fights cuz I didn't see a
clear win so that really like this game
transformed really quickly because I had
such a nice positional advantage and
then I got careless Queen B 1 was
actually a good move I shouldn't
probably just take on each six and why
didn't I take on each six I'm just upper
Brooke there - rookie six Bishop f6 but
good game Kluth was interesting
situation we had someone was saying f4
here yeah maybe f4 is playable f4 can be
probably mean probably met with that
three and I'm not chopping the bishop
but I would still have this in this I
just want it to be bit more giraffes
Triax thanks for the comments
little thing
thanks for the hundred bits people are
so kind I just wanted to quickly
evaluate this final position if King g2
instead so king g2 here because my rooks
are well connected my king is safe for
the time being but the issue is I don't
have anything immediate
I mean luck should still be better
somehow pawn count is equal but a7 is
hanging and then he would crush her at
u7 so maybe what I would do is play like
rookie 3 then rook FF 3 let me just okay
I'll guess the stock fish evaluation I
will guess or maybe what I would do I
would check him once more he would go
back I don't know what this accomplishes
though I would say it's like minus 1 but
I'm not sure let's check my computer is
so slow ok minus 0.5 so what's the line
King g1 rook f1 a6 was a computer move
rook f1 you know the yeah yeah it would
have been hard to win anyway I want the
computer to break my computer did that
make any sense I meant I didn't wanna I
meant just say I didn't want stock fish
to like just melts my computer anyway
who to play Joanna in the chat I was
about to end things but Joanna's here so
how could I end it you do like one more
I guess give me a random number between
I'm not sure I understand
no give me a random number between 1 and
17
[Music]
15:15 I already thought I already played
cacao ski though I could play them again
but so many other people are waiting
also my computer is really slowing down
and thanks for the comment Joanna Joanna
you didn't see my stream yesterday but
there is a large emphasis on the
trophies and how I'm getting rid of I'm
trying to get rid of them so I might
start auctioning them off or donate them
or someone said melt them and sell the
gold it's probably a good approach
looking for challenges here I just want
a quick game okay we'll play one of the
highest-rated people challenging me
who's also pretty hydrated and he's
provisional too don't think I played
this person before but yeah my computer
is starting to lag well he's only played
like five games good luck okay we'll try
and play some high quality chess why do
I want to get rid of them because they
take up space and I'm getting into the
whole the whole realm of minimalism and
I'm just trying to get rid of stuff that
don't sir it doesn't serve like too much
purpose I'll keep like the first-place
trophy is the ones that are memorable
but I just have too many like every turn
that I played scholastic chess and get a
trophy they build up okay so I'm playing
The Aleph in line playing out of six
here
interesting I'm okay with trading Queens
happy to play some queenless middle game
especially because he can't castle and I
have a D file I'll get her up to d8
before he can get it rook to d1 he just
resigns what ah maybe I was winning f2
yeah okay I guess he had to play Bishop
III but the positions already bad for uh
okay not that great for whites but okay
Bishop III I mean it's Lumia fights
nirvan Raymond has 18 trophies yeah I
have I've I don't know what the count is
probably close to 100 wait and so the
webcam is working right waits oh it's
not working this is my webcam which I
thought was it's it's like lit up I
thought I was turned on but it's
unfortunate so if I switch to switch
video capture
whoa I'm so white okay I know what's
wrong with this exposure it's supposed
to be like Auto I don't know why maybe
that's a sunlight coming in or something
this webcam is a it's a Logitech c920 I
believe I don't I haven't used it too
often cuz the built-in webcam on my
computer is is nice but okay I wanted to
switch webcams just to show some behind
the scenes that's trophies over there
that's trophies up there there's my blue
Yeti mic so there's a lot to sort
through anything and get rid of all I'll
take a picture of I probably already had
pictures of from from childhood so
anyway what to do o is pashka life go
back to the wait a minute
pashka ended the stream
okay I don't think I've ever done this
but for those of you who haven't been
watching for the full stream the first
like two or three minutes of this stream
I started on chess calm because I
thought there was an arena Kings
tournament today but somehow I miss
announcement that there was no
tournament because there's a match going
on between mvl and Komodo
and I played mvl a few weeks ago but not
in chess but in tennis and we also
played in bug house but anyway what I'm
gonna do is open this up and just go for
the raid so raid chess also why smite
monsters thanks for the hundred bits but
yeah I'm ending it here so I would
encourage everyone join the raid and and
enjoy some MVL versus Komodo action see
you guys